d'ailleurs j'ai dit est molle et claude
dernier vous vous rappelez toute
l'histoire de cette fête on va partir de
bathia du blé du sarrasin et puis on va
aller jusqu'à la crec geneviève elle
nous fait faire un joli voyage très
appétissant en tout cas pour terminer ce
journal pour faire de bonnes crêpes
il faut d'abord une bonne farine c'est à
dire un beau moulin comme celui le blé y
ait d'abord au cassé tous les meules de
pierre ou 10 subi une première
transformation
dans un second temps il est plus
finement broyées entre deux rouleaux
d'acier le produit de cette mouture est
longuement tamisée dans ces machines qui
comportent chacune 24 thani comme celui
alors la balle l'enveloppent qui entoure
la graine est isolé ce sera le son que
l'on donne aux ânes aux pochons enfin la
farine église elle est extrêmement fine
et d'excellente qualité
c'est de la farine de froment
on peut faire les mêmes choses avec ce
que l'on appelle le blé noir en fait le
sarrasin avec cette farine de sarrasin
de l'eau et du sel
on confectionne des galettes pressing
qui constitue même au moment de la
chandeleur le coeur du repas c'est le
celi ensuite on passe au sucré et c'est
la crème on l'a réalisé son à pâte à
crêpes on commence par mettre la farine
au milieu on fait un trou ça s'appelle
une fontaine dans lequel on est le sel
le sucre semoule 1 et ensuite 3e et avec
un fouet on commença à mélanger des
ingrédients peu à peu lorsque la pâte va
devenir un petit peu trop sèche et là on
va pratiquement y arriver on commence à
détendre avec le lait
je dirais que le secret de la
fabrication de cette pâte c'est d'éviter
de faire des grumeaux et c'est pour ça
que avant de mettre toute la quantité de
lait je vais incorporer le beurre fondu
et j'avais très bien quand il faut mais
faisait alors envoyez la à la
consistance où est arrivée la pâte
ça va être bon pour mettre le beurre
fondu une faune à pattes bien fluide
vous la laissez reposer pendant une
heure et vous pouvez y aller lors de la
chandeleur
on met effectivement une pièce de
monnaie dans sa main gauche et ont fait
sauter la crêpe avec la main droite
si la crêpe se retourne correctement
dans la poêle ça veut dire que pendant
tout le long de l'année on aura de la
chance et du bonheur vous avez compris
en définitive c'est très simple vous
prenez une pièce vous la mettez dans
votre main gauche pour les droitiers et
puis délit ou la crème au pardon